pierre je disais donc à l'instant vous
êtes avec les policiers scientifiques
il dénonce bien évidemment la réforme
des retraites comme tous les autres
appelé à cette manifestation mais aussi
la question de leur statut n'est ce pas
eh bien écoutez c'est tout à fait ça à
mira pour les policiers du service
technique et scientifique c'est toujours
le problème le même problème le problème
de statuer notamment en ce qui concerne
la retraite puisque les agents de la
police technique et scientifique dispose
d'un statut administratif quand leurs
homologues de la police nationale
traditionnelle dispose d'un statut
actifs ce qui leur permet parfois et
dans certains cas hâte de pouvoir partir
à la retraite à 52 ans alors c'est ça
que demandent aujourd'hui les agents de
la police technique et scientifique un
statut de métier à risque puisque depuis
plus de dix ans maintenant il travaille
avec un gilet pare-balles et sont amenés
à rencontrer des scènes parfois très
brutal c'est en tout cas parce que nous
expliqué xavier de pays tiers le
secrétaire national policier
scientifique je vous propose de
l'écouter
[Musique]
ce qu'on voit sur les scènes ben voyons
quand on parle de l'afertes roannaise on
a des corps démembrés
on arrive sur des viols on arrive sur
des scènes de ta tante à deux
catastrophes de masse voilà tout ça
c'est c'est de la pénibilité finalement
mentale et donc c'est à plusieurs
reprises que les policiers technique et
scientifique manifeste ont manifesté
cette année des policiers un qui vit
forcément comme une injustice alors
différence de statut avec leurs
homologues de la police nationale on le
rappelle les effectifs de la police
technique et scientifique il représente
seulement 2% des effectifs totaux de la
police nationale et les policiers un
techniques et scientifiques sont à
l'origine de 30 % des résolutions des
enquêtes
merci pierre pour toutes ces précisions